[Music]
hey guys make sure to follow at she
teachings game on Instagram to the
excellency exclusive content really cool
challenges and some really cool gameplay
also make sure that cruise on over to
the description box below so you guys
can click on the link for our
Kickstarter make that pledge to get your
box alright because it's ending soon and
you'll no longer be able to get it I'm
not kidding and Bad Girls Club news
submitted by NGOs right hook oh is that
the one that gave Bart the bloody nose
we're not friends anymore don't talk to
me you're so pretty today though I don't
care thank you a reality TV star has
been arrested and charged with fraud who
a girl from the Bad Girls Club which who
is that Papa John's
what is the Papa John get that from
alright so I saw something Instagram
with Papa John's
I saw that I don't know there's actually
a Papa John liked the name like the guy
it's one CEO his name what altar
University living in Papa John's take it
home or what goes it goes Papa John's
your mattress is free Papa Murphy's take
and bake that's what that was ok yeah no
no this is John's mission ater I think
is his name John Smith John Smith Oh
Papa John's is the one that comes with
the pepperoncini in the butter oh yeah
yeah yeah that's what it was
yo would not oh don't you love a pizza
though where you don't talk about the
pizza you like you comes with the butter
in the peppers
that's right that's true that's how
[ __ ] shitty the pizza that the
accessories with that much better
yeah thank you this man I got so this
celebrity reality TV shows celebrity
whatever her name is Sinead Claremont
have you heard of the Claremont twins
nope yeah neither have I until I resume
but apparently there's good tip you burn
the [ __ ] out of though June it was just
with extreme prejudice she put them down
you was nothing like she Terminator
walking normal just so cool what I loved
it alright oh she the twin Oh first of
all this is what she looked at Sinead
Claremont she's the one that has been
arrested what's up she used a dead man's
debit card okay never mind not listener
she met him for prostitution purposes
wow so she's pretty much doing the same
job an actress the prostitute now we're
talking all acting you hear that reality
TV star prostitute what's the difference
don't you blog I know what you want to
make movies an [ __ ] yeah exactly what
star dear friends okay alright he's not
excluding himself I am he's a part of it
I'm not looking down I'm just saying
it's the same thing baby dating facts
cam girl vlogger what's the difference
that's pretty sure where it's like it's
a comp to me and asked me about it to me
please
yeah alright so here's your twin
the Clermont whoa what is they also came
out and easy easy season they were
models oh that's right I remember they
were naked and topless oh hell no they
don't walk the same why are they
prostituting they're so hot
that's why they're prostituting their 24
years oh the high level high level
processor passing on a charge 400 that's
it do they [ __ ] together that's what I
want oh dude there are there are
realities hey look it's not gross
anymore okay that's the most top search
[ __ ] now what twin [ __ ] no in sister
stuff Oh Oh twisties you just chill with
your judgey ass lid on it all right so
there's like text conversation that she
had with the victim and on one of them
like in this conversation that I have
here it says the victim says or you want
to be the victim
yeah let's do it okay what do you want
to do I want to see you for the amount
we agreed on so you tell me duck lips
let's do 400 yeah that's it how far are
you from 53rd and second I 150 4th and
10th the 7:30 work maybe just come over
now don't have to get all dressed up mmm
okay smiley face I'll be there around
5:15 XO okay I'm a cool dude you'll have
fun what type of booze do you like wine
wine works what's your address
I'm 250 East 53rd apartment Sens
apartment number okay babe we'll let you
know when I'm on my way
XO can you set another face plate pic
fave pic you deleted me on the site and
then she sends photos that appeared to
depict her the defendant posing I wanted
to be juiced that was such a boring tame
it was it was very boring and I actually
didn't plan on reading this conversation
for you guys while I did this but four
hundred dollars I throw something yeah
baby like all the good stuff
yeah well I think that that Dalek date I
got that I got that I got the like
cougar transaction stuff all wrong what
did you think it was I thought was gonna
be more specific like how much for a
[ __ ] $35 well how about if I want my
ball
take hold maybe an extra $5 maybe tongue
my [ __ ] left sack and and and but
probably because of code right you don't
want to say it quite like that so it's
like how much to have a wet lamppost and
she's like wet lamppost for a dry
lamppost
700 he's like why is the drops are more
expensive and she's like you'll see
winky face
how much for a hole in one
and she's like thousand these sounds a
little too well brother what is going on
your bed have I used provider websites
to for cure call girl have you
absolutely not
well yours is better yours is better
than the actual thing that's what I
wanted I wanted something really special
the thing you asked about let the
conversation and the 400 so then that's
why I read it but anyway the point is
here that man I've never done it in my
life right that's pretty good
he's a shady agent for sure apparently
she racked up to $20,000 on the debit
cards of this dead man but he's already
dead so who needs the money
oh I'm just like well no put the credit
card still pays a'right isn't metal
debit card I was a debit card it's
actually his money has his money she's
just taking money than nobody would ever
use passed down the family she doesn't
deserve it either so same thing yeah so
apparently when they searched the man's
room they revealed a broken condom a
clear bag containing cocaine a rolled up
dollar bill and a possible fentanyl
tablet oh that should become a okay so
apparently he died from an overdose of
course I'm pretty sure I could have
figured it out from the evidence laid
out oh you're so smart but but then he
impregnated someone because of the bus
that caught
what's with the brownie condoms
everywhere why did that they include
that yeah what does it torn cotton that
have to do with anything
Nick it has been like condoms all up I
even then so does it makes like why does
that yeah big deal we say if it's a used
condom like they always say you have you
noticed that yeah complete supports and
[ __ ] you gotta go always sure I never
hear an open pack of Trojans on the
[ __ ] dresser I never hear that [ __ ]
it's because we want to know right so
they do it in code so that we understand
I'll come by don't say like three tulips
on the coffee table do tell me but dude
it's like when Diane Sawyer is talking
to like a victim of like some serious
like well you know when I'm with that
girl got kidnapped by that dude was
taken in the woods she was like 15 years
I'm sure smart yeah and she was taken in
the woods yeah man smarter Emily smart
something what happened well no she got
taken the woods by this guy right uh-huh
and then brought back and then Diane
Sawyer and all these people were
interviewing her and they're like what
happened in the woods did he do anything
like sexually [ __ ] and it's like and
they do that because we all want to know
see even though it's horrible we all
want enough medicine the primals
probably exactly I want to know the
details because that story yeah so
they're not blaming her for that OD um
not to my knowledge they're just doing
the whole it's separate events the whole
fraud thing because she was she created
a fake email address for this man and
like she was buying plane tickets and
paid her phone bill with that card and
your and her red whatever why would you
fight your own phone but what if he like
she made more than $400 what if he was
like Dan that [ __ ] was so good here
go on a shopping spree like I've seen
that in movies where they give the girl
like their card
wait a minute they're coming debit cards
like pretty woman pretty woman he never
got to blow any load that pisses me off
when I see that movie know that Hayden's
according to Joe there's in between them
so you're basing this off a pretty woman
I know because he refused to remember
that scene with shoes trying to finally
she was like do you know what I gotta
give you some kind of service I feel
useless and she was trying to [ __ ] him
he's like no get off me [ __ ] yeah
kind of power play was that they used to
doing he's a gentle man
steer but not when she was hooking
anymore yeah but they made love like Top
Gun style yeah they [ __ ] for free I
can't believe that fool was that stupid
that he didn't know she was a hooker
this whole time but every time I think
of him I think of dribbling Julia
Roberts hot or not that movie hot hell
ha ha ha ha
when Erin Brockovich hella ha oh ha ha
Ella I got one I'll give it to you you
guys tell me all you don't [ __ ] like
a lady actor performers
I want to [ __ ] her in the in that age
she was he's like you all think I [ __ ]
weird chicks he's like well I would [ __ ]
this chick you've all agreed the two
[ __ ] you so well conversation we had
three months I know about Britney Spears
cuz it's still weird that he wouldn't
[ __ ] madney's Britney Spears that's the
weirdest [ __ ] could you hold it against
me I do man I do I judge you yeah I'm
trying to win you over so this girl here
she's not this way she's facing a
maximum year of 20 years in prison or
jail she did get bailed out by her twin
sister and she's released under $100,000
bond would she use the guy's credit card
for yeah better sister trade places what
there's something never mind yeah hell
yeah
[Music]